good morning everyone hi y'all doing
great I know we're running behind so I'm
gonna just try to roll with this talk as
best as I can
my name is Pandi and I'm super honored
to be here you may know about me I'm the
automation Panda I'm not gonna give a
big introduction to myself because this
talk will tell quite a bit about my
story what I will say though starting
off is that I love Python and that's the
starting point of why we're here to talk
about surviving without Python I first
conceived this talk actually at last
year's PI Ohio so it's only fitting that
I get to give it here so I want to take
you back on the story oh thank you I
want to talk to you about my Python
journey my Python journey actually
started in high school it's born and
raised in Baltimore I attended Parkville
high school for math science computer
science and in ninth grade I got this
lovely thing called a ti-83 plus
graphing calculator how many people had
this thing oh it was magical yeah pretty
much everybody right I taught myself how
to program on this first it was math
formulas than games and I just went
crazy from there as part of my high
school program I started doing C++ and
then Java and as a part of a survey
course in 12th grade senior year I was
first it was my first encounter with
Python
back then it was Python 2.7 it was
really cool I had a lot of fun with it
some reason I also end up doing some
COBOL I don't just think that off
whatever but I had an amazing high
school program i I really got into
programming and I did Python starting
12th grade and I promptly never went
back until 2015 nine years later I by
that point I was a software engineer and
test doing a lot of testing and
automation I worked at IBM I worked at
net app I did four years of test
automation in Perl don't do that but
then I got hired by this company called
Max point if you anybody been to pi day
to carolina's this greg here in the
front rows wearing the t-shirt they were
on the sponsors for that I was pretty
cool and Max point was a three language
shop C sharp C sharp Java and Python so
I knew Java C sharp is basically Java
and then I was like oh hi thon is cool
again let me try this
and I started using it heavily for my
test automation there it was awesome I
really really fell in love with Python
all over again
nine years later some of the things I
loved about Python I loved that it was
easy to learn I loved that it was
concise it was elegant it was readable
it was command-line friendly so I could
use it in Jenkins it had packages for
everything you could imagine and can I
mention Pi test PI test is awesome
especially for me being a tester guy
this is so cool I could do amazing
things in Python very quickly I could
write command line tools I could just
get things up and going and it really
brought me back to the joy of coding
right and so I found out oh wow
I think I'm a pythonista I think this is
me oh wow
so if you may have heard this term
before but the basic definition of a PI
still pythonista is a person who loves
the Python programming language and I
was like this is it me I love this I I
absolutely love to use Python it's so
easy it's so fun I feel like I can do so
much with so little verbage so yeah I
self-identified it's a Python ISTA and
that was great until 2016 things happen
you know software's tumultuous I ended
up leaving that company for a greater
opportunity elsewhere but as part of
that job transition I ended up no longer
doing Python as part of my day to day
work and so hence the inspiration for
this talk I had to end up surviving
without Python hmm but there's a hard
truth here and that's the fact that
there's more to the software world than
just Python right we're here to Python
conference and we probably go to other
Python conferences and we do our Python
talks on Python Python Python because
we're pythonista s'right but there is
there's more to software than just
Python right it's it's not the one-stop
solution for everything there's a bit
there's a bit of a bubble that we need
to pop around ourselves and it's
regardless of frameworks languages
packages domain or speciality all right
and I have evidence to back this up
right back or this year earlier this
year
stackoverflow did a developer survey I
don't know if anybody took it or saw the
results Python had a very strong showing
of the most popular programming
scripting and markup languages you can
see Python was rated at number four at
41% but it is not the number one
JavaScript is dominating that game for
better or worse and there are still
other languages like Java and c-sharp
they tend to dominate back-end systems
are in Scala though they're not as high
in the rankings that were farther down
the list particularly for League data
science and work JavaScript is all over
the front end so different domains have
different languages that are strong in
those areas it's not just languages but
it's also things like frameworks if you
look at web frameworks it should be no
surprise that javascript is all over the
top our beloved Jango and flask make a
showing but they're way way down right
so there's a good chance if you're doing
web development you're going to end up
not doing Python or you're going to do
Python along with something like
JavaScript and just straight up any type
of framework whether it's web or not
again
Python frameworks like pandas and tensor
flow make a strong showing but they're
not the only ones out there right
there's some c-sharp things and there's
some dotnet things and there's
JavaScript things so we live in a very
interesting world with very diverse
technologies languages tools and
frameworks so if you're in this tech
space you like me you may end up working
on non Python projects and that's okay
and I'm here to tell you it's gonna be
ok so let's so the question then becomes
as Python East --is how do we survive
without Python how are we going to live
and work and breathe and enjoy what we
do if we don't get to use our favorite
language or language or technologies or
frameworks that we love and so my answer
to that is even if we don't use Python
for everything we can still take
inspiration from pythons principles
projects and people and we can apply
that to whatever we are working on to
make things great so let's start off by
talking about principles when I say
principles I'm talking about the
principles that come from the Zen of
Python for Yahoo may not know the Zen of
Python is a set of
guiding principles for the design and
implementation of the Python language
it's a there's an Easter egg and the
interpreter if you go to a command line
and you type import this it'll dump the
Zen of Python in 20 points mm-hmm I'm
sure probably everybody's seen this
recently Adrian lo gave an awesome talk
about this so I definitely recommend
check that out on YouTube but let's look
at three in particular that I think can
apply well to other spaces the first
point that I love is beautiful is better
than ugly beautiful is better than ugly
there's an aesthetic to the Python
programming language and there's an
aesthetic to how we go and write Python
ik code right it's not my quote but it's
out there code is art that does
something I don't know if anybody's
heard this before this this this
resonates very much with me is like oh
yes code is art that does something we
should take pride in the work that we do
whether we're writing some test cases or
whether we're developing a web front-end
or whether we're doing some back-end
systems or we're analyzing data system
setting up AI whatever the thing is we
are craftsmen and crafts women we should
take pride in our work because we are
creative beings right we're all here
learning about the thing that we're
doing because we love doing it in some
sense nobody's forcing us to do this
kind of work right well-formed
utterances of logic and reason bring
order to solutions out of the chaos of
problems right
we're solution bringers we're solution
makers there are problems in the world I
need to set up this pipeline I need to
solve this really tricky thing that's
affecting people's lives how can I do
that by the power of software right we
can use the powers of logic and reason
as we make our code to really solve good
problems and bring about good solutions
and this is very much art right we use
technology and we go through a process
of engineering but a lot of times the
formation of these solutions and how we
implement that really comes down to an
art right and so this this art that we
apply to solution bringing and problem
solving is language independent we can
do it in some Python we could do this in
Java we could do this in any language
that's available right
beautiful is better than ugly I really
first learned this lesson when I was in
high school at Parkville high school in
tenth grade I took a Java course and it
was really cool because I got to kind of
it was I got to treat it almost like an
independent study where I just cram and
through all the examples in the textbook
and have fun time and I remember I
forget when it was in the course but
there was a lesson on recursion
I'm sure how many people have hit
recursion and broke their brain over it
yeah it's one of those things it's like
you okay you've learned basic
programming HelloWorld you've done the
conditional statements and loops and
you've probably done a little bit with
classes and listen arrays okay now
recursion let's just boom write a
function calling itself how is this
gonna work oh my gosh am i blowing my
stack right it was really challenging
for me as an early you know programmer
trying to wrap my head around this but
my textbook had this incredible activity
for teaching recursion and was this
thing called a Koch curve I don't know
if anybody's seen this before but the
idea is you have a line and then you put
a triangle in the middle of it and you
keep breaking down the segments and keep
making little triangles on top of those
and if you arrange three of these lines
and do this algorithm recursively you'll
get this beautiful picture of a
snowflake isn't this cool right it's
kind of recursive he keeps adding up a
going and there's all sorts of fun it's
like wow that that snowflake looks
pretty cool but look look at the
algorithm that makes this snowflake
like it's it's just recursive calls you
if you hit your base case you stop but
otherwise you you determine your length
side is gonna be a third of what it was
before and you go straight you turn left
your cursive call you make it go
straight again you turn right again and
this is the code this is now I did it in
Java originally but this is a Python
version of this code and and the thing
that really struck me and I'm so glad I
hit this like life lesson in tenth grade
at the very early point of my
programming career what I found was
beautiful was not so much the snowflake
but the algorithm right I saw beauty in
the algorithm that it made sense that it
was so elegant and simple and the fact
that the snowflake is beautiful is a
side effect of the algorithm being
beautiful and that blew my mind right I
was like wow that's amazing
when you do things well and you craft it
well good things happen as a consequence
and I just that just invigorated me so
much more if you like this is an amazing
thing we can use the metaphysical
building blocks of logic and reason the
underpinnings of our very universe to
make awesome things happen right and I
knew from that moment I wanted to pursue
this kind of thing for my life right
beautiful is better than ugly so let's
take pride in our work let's make sure
we're making awesome things right and
that can apply to anything another
tenant of the Zen of Python is simple is
better than complex right simple is
better than complex if we can do things
simply it's gonna be better for
everybody around right now how do we
read a file well you write some code and
you read the file in and some memory
right here's a Java implementation of
reading a file this code is kind of ugly
now it may be a little bit unfair
because there's some improvements in the
Java language that make this little bit
simpler but historically you'd have to
like read an input stream and do a
buffering and like read it with a loop
and do all this kind of trimming and
stuff and then close it is very very
complicated I think you're probably
looking at this right now like oh my
gosh this is what people do in Java yes
this is what people do in Java sometimes
sorry Java I love you but sometimes it
hurts right how would we write this in
Python Wow true story I'm not making
this it's the same kind of stuff right
simple is better than complex when we
have fewer lines of code we have simpler
calls is going to make our our
development experience better it's going
to make the product better it's going to
improve maintainability it helps lower
the bar so other people can come in and
contribute as well these are the kinds
this is the kind of code that is
objectively better I would say right so
this was like a simple construct of a
particular thing of small thing common
thing loading a reading a file but how
can we apply this idea of simplifying
our code to other languages that may be
more of a Bose than Python there's a few
things we can do and I do this every day
in c-sharp because for some reason for
the past three years I'm a.net developer
like I tell people that you go to all
the Python conference your thought not
definite yes really
or your this is a joke right no it's
actually not a anyway it's not a bad
thing it's cool but hey so how can we
write pythonic code in other languages
things like writing small functions and
methods instead of big ones right using
short lines instead of very long chains
using line continuations for rather
lengthy strings avoiding unnecessary
curly braces maybe that's just a pet
peeve of mine but uh simple loops and
list comprehensions rather than nested
down the wazoo right
these are all very pythonic things that
we know it's Python encouraged use as a
language to adopt these better practices
but it doesn't mean you can't do them in
other languages as well oh my gosh mean
I overlooked that I just take it for
granted right yeah so bingo bingo mm a
third thing from the zen of python that
i like to highlight is readability
counts right and this hits home for me
because not only am i software engineer
but i'm a software engineer in test that
means the main focus of what I'm
developing are test automation solutions
so if we look at the domain of software
testing we we really got to recognize
the readability leads to
understandability and leads to
maintainability right in software
testing we want to describe our
behaviors using plain language and we
know our test cases are going to cover
those behaviors and our automation is
going to implement those test cases so I
want to make sure that backtracking from
my script to the test to the behavior of
which I'm testing that should all be
very intuitive right I shouldn't have to
look at a test script to wonder how the
heck did I end up with this
in Python this is pretty nice right PI
test
I love PI test who loves PI test oh yes
thank you you warm my heart and soul I
gave a tutorial nasai went to talk to
Esther damn pi test is just the best
thing ever I can write tests and PI test
right it's great I can write web UI
tests and PI tests in fact this is a
snippet for my tutorial from yesterday
right in my test cases that I write
I can I can add helpful comments to show
exactly what I'm doing
I can use design patterns like page
objects to describe hey I'm going to go
to a search page I'm going to load the
page I'm going to search for something
I'm gonna go to the results page and
check things on that page very intuitive
very readable I can also write my tests
in a behavior driven development style
if anybody's heard of that using a
language called gherkin has anybody
heard of gherkin yeah I live in gherkin
land that's my life I do that in c-sharp
instead of Python but on the right I've
written the same test that's on the left
but I've written it as a gherkin feature
file and this is all plain language
given the DuckDuckGo homepage is
displayed when the user searches for
Panda then the results are shown right
so this idea of readability is rather
universal it's not it's a hallmark of
Python but it doesn't have to be only
for Python right when I write my tests I
write them in gherkin and then I have C
sharp automation code underneath it'll
implement each line by line step so
readability counts readability is a good
thing and we can apply that outside of
the Python space so everybody tracking
with me here yeah cool so now that we've
talked a lot about principles let's move
on to our next P because peas are for
pandas peas or for pythons and peas are
for the three points of our slides yes
projects projects can use Python in cool
ways even if it's on the side right like
I said my main project at my company I
develop a test automation solution in
dotnet using speck flow and webdriver
we've have a full web UI test solution
that runs way too many tests every day
continuously overnight right right so
that is that's what you would call my
main product my main project and my main
product is a c-sharp solution but I can
still use Python elsewhere and so can we
right
last year at PyCon Larry Hastings gave a
really cool talk call solve your
problems with sloppy Python the thesis
of his talk was this right
Python is great for quick and dirty
things if you need to write a script
once to do some tasks and then throw it
away that's totally cool it doesn't
matter if it's not the best practices
for your code did it get the job done
and you moved on with your life
cool good enough for some things things
like if you need command-line tools or
you need to make a text or data munging
script cuz you got a load like but [ __ ]
bytes of data once into a system and
that's it or if you want to do something
like rapid prototyping import this
import that import everything you can
imagine slap it all together and boom
you have a product write Python it's
great so even if the price even if
python may not be the main technology
for a product you can still help you get
there right keep that in mind and if you
want to learn more about things that
Python can do it's particularly in the
world of automation I recommend reading
these books as well right if the product
is not written in Python them maybe its
support can be maybe your test cases for
your web app can be written in Python
maybe you can do some sysadmin scripts
to help you out write Python can help
and maybe it's not a project at your day
job but maybe you're moonlighting on
something fun fact did you know I once
owned a suit and dress tailoring
business I live an interesting life it's
strange but true how did this work well
what we would do is we would meet
customers here in the u.s. we would take
their measurements yes I had to take
people's measurements yes it got awkward
at times it's cool take their
measurements they pick out those
materials their style points there's so
much that goes into these suits oh my
gosh if you need to tell her making suit
I could just believe her all the details
about this all day but we're not here
for that we would do this then we would
send all these things off to Shanghai
and China and we would have them made by
expert tailors who've been doing this
for years and then import the suits back
into the US do final fitting and
everybody's hopefully happy or they're
angry because it didn't come back right
let's not talk about this right now you
might be wondering Annie why are you
taking this this side-trip talking about
suits this is a Python conference well
business problems get software solutions
how did I solve the business problems by
the power of Python and specifically
with Django for all of our order
processing
I built a django web app right because
there were there's customer data there
were measurements there were orders that
had to go in we had to track status as
orders or in the pipeline right so I
built a web app in Python to solve all
these business problems I threw out my
data models I used the admin site there
was no real front end because myself and
my wife and a few other partners were
the only ones who logged in so I used
the Adminsitration
I hosted it on Heroku it was awesome
stored our customer data in a Postgres
database stored our pictures and images
in Amazon s3 and here's a really cool
part you put it in order you click a
button you would download a receipt with
all the details give it to the customer
you click another button you download
the receipt and it's automatically
translated into Chinese and we would
send that oh excuse me we send that off
to the tailors in Shanghai my wife is
from China by the way hence this whole
hook up but like for each individual
order she would spend like half an hour
translating from English to Chinese by
hand in addition to all the problems of
you didn't get this measurement or that
measurement right I took that half hour
and eliminated it down to like a split
second I'm pretty proud about that
that's a pretty cool trick so and also
it also did some some calculations on
the back end so I use Python to solve
that very real problem we had and that
was just something that you know as a
side business right now
that business is no longer operating
thank goodness I get some time back but
if my plans were to take it to the next
step is well I could have just made a
front-end for that and had customers
just go online and place orders there
and if I had done that I would have done
a hybrid thing where I was looking at
using angular for my front-end making a
jangula app right so Python can work
with other frameworks I didn't make this
term up it's out there google it right
but the thought is like Python can work
with other things like we saw javascript
is dominating popularity out there we'll
see how long that lasts javascript love
it or hate it it's there right
but python if it can't be in the front
end of the browser though some things
may make that change it can work with
things like JavaScript or maybe you use
Django rest framework or you use flask
instead of Django or use react or view
j/s
right
I can work with other things too all in
the project space finally I'd like to
talk about people this is my favorite
part
people build strong healthy community
and we're all here at PI Ohio I'm
assuming we're having a good time
right I love Python conferences yeah you
all love them too right you're here cuz
of community or maybe you're here for
the language but what you're gonna find
out is you're also going to be here for
the community right but it doesn't good
community doesn't have to be limited to
Python right and we'll see how so raise
your hand if any of these bullet points
has been true for you you got stuck on a
programming problem you struggled to
understand a concept you felt alone
isolated imposter syndrome you'll want
it to give up I'm gonna turn around and
let's see everybody's hand is raised
that's not surprising right was anyone
there to help you all out yeah that's
why you're here now whoa thank those
people we just had a keynote on that
right that's the basis of community
that's why we come to these things and
help each other out it's awesome isn't
it
yes it's awesome it's frequently said
people come to Python for the language
but stay for the community and that was
very much true of my story right I had
no reason to to really engage the Python
community after I had left that one
employer in 2016 but it's it's 2019
right I think so yeah
I'm still here I'm given talks about
this it's amazing right I think what
really helped me engage the Python
community was I went to PyCon 2018 that
was I had been to PI data Carolina's
before but I wasn't really like in the
community at that point this PyCon 2018
was like the first time I really was
like engaging the community I already
had a language I loved adore a built in
Django app and done a ton of testing but
now it's like okay let me let me try
this thing out so I went I saw the
Django girls and I thank them for their
awesome documentation for helping me
solve tailoring problems right
I met the founder of Pi bytes or
co-founder Jason or Julian I met a
friend from RIT and I scored so much
swag right and I had an amazing time
it was so inspirational I mean I write a
whole blog post about like all the
wonderful things that happened I wish I
had more time
here in this talk to talk about it but I
got to move on come talk to me
afterwards but that started this crazy
thing of Pandi Knights World Tour I went
to from PyCon to PI Ohio to Pike Gotham
to Pike on Canada to Pike Caribbean spy
Texas and then finally back to Pike on
2019 and then of course well here this
is the next one
but Pike on 2019 for me felt more like a
reunion because with these amazing
conferences I had met so many amazing
people many of them are here in the
front row thank you that it was just
like wow I feel like I belong and soap
icon 2019 was just phenomenal and like
all these people are people I've met
along the way each one of these is an
expert at something amazing many of them
are here in the audience today to listen
to my talk because they support me we
had a road trip from Raleigh North
Carolina as the PI Carolinas delegation
to be here at this conference
that's how awesome this community is
right there's there's some guy whoa
yes yes like this photo was taken at
Eden burger a year ago today that's my
friend Julian when we meet he's from
Australia by the way he came a long way
right that's PI Texas that's the PI
Carolina's open space this is the
announcing of all the different
conferences that's a guy who's also from
Raleigh that's just the Pokemon company
they were there I love Pokemon there's
amazing things are happening in this
community and so I want to make it clear
conference friends or real friends and
it's amazing the things you can do
and it's so amazing I'm trying to make
this happen in Carolina I love it so
much I'm trying to get a PI Carolina's
2020 is probably gonna be in June and
Raleigh a lot of people are helping out
help me make it happen get on slack and
all that stuff but all that to say right
this doesn't have to be exclusive to
Python this is something python is very
good at doing but you can take it to
your own community so you can take it
back to your tribes as our keynote
speaker set to your workplace to your
open-source projects to your other
languages and technologies and groups
and all that right what we've done in
Python doesn't have to stay in Python
and that's a one that's how we can
survive without Python we can take the
awesome things the principles the
projects the people and take them
elsewhere so much my my challenge to all
of you TLDR be inspired to do great
things
thank you very much
[Applause]
you